what I love about this one so much is
you take Hellboy you take that R rating
and you just crank it up to 11 I thought
it was great that we could really lean
into the R rating I think it's super
authentic to the source material you
know Mike's the comics are dark they're
funny they're violent they're a little
weird and and all of this stuff can be
translated freely with an R rating
where's my violin ed skrein was
initially cast as your character and
then he stepped down you know
recognizing the whitewashing controversy
I'm curious what an action like that
means to you from your perspective I
mean so much because it highlights the
fact that those of us who have suffered
from whitewashing can fight all we want
but what's more important that it's a
collective effort not just on the part
of minorities but all of us you know it
takes someone like Edie to make a
gesture like that to move the needle and
it wouldn't have happened without it so
I'm really indebted to him and I have so
much respect for what he did and I hope
you know he can set an example for
others and had a little dinner - I saw
we did yeah you know I was so moved by
what he did that I actually you know
sought him out when I was in London and
he was nice enough to come out and have
lunch with me and we talked and we've
become friends come on PTAs honor
yeah come on let's do this it's
obviously you know a complete movie but
there are there are some setups for
things that could happen in the future
and here's what you want to see in a
sequel they do tease a couple of things
I want to see how that stuff plays out
and I'd love to see daimyo story-arc
kind of play out similarly to the way it
is in the original comics because he's
got some interesting stuff to do there's
a whole space where I'm like he could
have his own spin-off oh well what see
[Music]